well nothing says i love you like a
beautiful bouquet of flowers or several
for that matter and just in time for
valentine's day we are talking all price
points to find the perfect gift for the
one you love joining us today is florist
flower expert and ceo savannah eileen
savannah thanks for being here hi
everyone so we have a bunch of products
here today i'm so excited to show you
yeah it looks amazing where should we
start okay so we'll start off by like
our most popular items
our most popular item for this
valentine's day is like our angel
bouquets this is an array of 50 roses
and they come in different shades and
colors
these range at 295 so this is like our
more extravagant piece okay i like
extravagant and these smell amazing
let's say if you want to know you know
not go as extravagant not as extravagant
one of our most trendy pieces is like
our little hello kitty bouquet these
ones range for 120 and they'll be
available in store on valentine's day oh
my gosh that's so cute i didn't even
notice it's a hello kitty i love it okay
a little something for everyone okay so
everyone let's move over here we even
have plants i know there's some girls
that aren't like really the flower type
so we have different plants oh my gosh
you've thought of all of it and i i keep
looking at the phone teddy's yeah tell
me all about it so we have our foam
teddies they range from about 60 to 135
we have a bunch of different colors we
have like pandas and unicorns so it
doesn't only have to be for the girl in
your life it could be for your daughter
your cousin anybody can honestly get
like a foam teddy oh my gosh so all of
that is made out of foam it's not real
flour so it'll last forever and it's a
it's a cool thing to put on your vanity
to remember forever valentine's day
savannah i like you because i always
kill my flowers and my plants so this is
the perfect way to last forever to make
it last okay what do we have over here
so over here we have like a cute little
glass rose these go for 35 and they
light up oh my gosh and we'll have a
bunch of different stuff in store like
here is like a two dozen these range
from around 120.
and then here i am always drawn to the
pieces
we have a one dozen here these go for 85
in store and then this is our korean
wrapping so it's something that you
could just throw into a vase and it
doesn't need to be unwrapped or anything
it'll stay beautiful forever yeah this
is so beautiful and i love the wrapping
in the bow and i can't everything just
smells so amazing i can only imagine
what your shop must be taken of people
want to come by tell them where you're
located and if they should order in
advance or how it all works so we're
located on charleston and ellis you can
go on eileen entertainment.com and
pre-order your bouquet or you can just
come in store on valentine's day and
we'll have even more options than what
you see on this table also even last
minute
last minute yes
we'll have thousands of bouquets so you
guys can come and choose whatever
catches your eye and i looked up your
social media you're so fun to follow on
there you show all different fun things
and so where can people find you if they
want to see more so you can go on our
instagram it's ileane.entertainment we
have a twitter we have a facebook we
have a tick tock we have every social
media platform so just look up our
company name and we're there
eileen thank you so much you smell
amazing i'm claiming these you can be my
valentine this year yay eileen thank you
so much jc i'll send it over to you the
mom museum